oder eine debatte im britischen
unterhaus ist schon etwas ganz
besonderes
mir wird gejohlt und gelacht geschrien
und wild gestikuliert immer wieder
musiker john bercow die abgeordneten zur
ordnung rufen
so weit so skurril
doch was nach einem chaotischen
polittheater aussieht folgt in wahrheit
klaren regeln und uralten ritualen steht
ein abgeordneter während der debatte auf
signalisiert er dass er etwas sagen oder
fragen möchte nur wem der speaker das
wort erteilt darf sprechen
regierungsmitglieder und opposition
wechseln sich in der regel ab der
applaus ist verpönt zustimmung wird
durch ein kurzes hier hier kundgetan
auch ihre ablehnung dürfen die
abgeordneten lautstark äußern mit
ein echter und werden
bemerkungen wird es dem speaker zu wild
schreitet er ein und ermahnt die
abgeordneten die parlamentarier
adressieren ihre beiträge stets an den
speaker direkte ansprachen untereinander
werden in der regel genügen die redezeit
ist anders als in vielen parlamenten
unbegrenzt
der speaker darf aber unterbrechen wenn
ein abgeordneter sich wiederholt und die
debatte nicht voranbringen auf der
debatte folgt die abstimmung mit einem
lauten oder no signalisieren die
abgeordneten ihre zustimmung oder
ablehnung
wenn das ergebnis nicht eindeutig ist
kommt es zu einer abstimmung per
hammelsprung verfahren die abgeordneten
getreten zwei räume geben dort ihre
stimmen ab der speaker verkündet
anschließend das ergebnis rechtmäßig
tagen kann das parlament übrigens nur
wenn der sogenannte streitkolben auf der
tafel des house of commons gut ein
zeremoniell es zepter als symbol für die
autorität des königshauses
im dezember gab es einen skandal der
abgeordnete lloyd russell hatte aus
protest den streitkolben entwendet und
wurde anschließend von speaker john
bercow rausgeschmissen
st